all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning coffee
uh like the video on your way in that's
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these streams um so
today I wanted to talk about let me show
you one this travesty how do chicks have
like three bags on vacation I'm going to
save you the most time I travel all the
time for
work it is life is easier when you can
just put everything in a little bag wash
clothes on the trip I don't know why you
chicks some men too to be honest are got
bag bag bag it's just like that's a
hassle anyways so today I have my
morning
coffee I'm about to go to the airport um
I am going to see my dad for his
birthday I saw this liberal guy raging
it was really funny now guys I have to
be honest I am a
flaker now I'm not a flaker I'm not a
flaker
because um a disrespectful thing
although maybe sometimes it comes off
that way and this is a area of who I am
as a person that could probably be
improved probably right you
know
um
so this um liberal kid I was supposed to
do this like debate with and I really um
what happens is I'm I overbook myself at
times and then I'll kind of look at my
calendar for the week and I'll be like H
I have too much going
on and then I'll just start to take a
couple people off cuz I just can't
handle it yeah sorry guys you know I
mean I'm I'm I'm human and I saw this
guy just raging online saying I'm like
trying to duck
him and it was very interesting I was
like
huh and the thing is now I was like
well if you're the run to the internet
type after we have a reschedule and
you're going to cry about it well I'll
just never reschedule why would I
reschedule with someone that's going to
cry every time things don't go their way
do you know how many times I've been
rescheduled on in my life it's part of
the isn't it anyways so funny funny
thing the other thing that I saw
recently was I saw these post wall women
and it was so funny I I think they were
like between the ages of 29 at the
youngest to like 35 roughly maybe 37 I
don't
know and these chicks um it was really
interesting they they raged about me for
like 45 minutes on this panel they're
just just talking about how ugly I am
and
how um you know I'm just a hateful woman
I'm usually in a pretty good mood I'm
usually pretty happy but you know they
that's what they felt they felt like I
was very hateful and evil
and so what was my crime what was my CRI
I would
imagine they had a laundry list of
crimes that I
committed
my crime was saying that younger women
are hotter than them yes yes ladies
you're not competing with any 22y olds
for men's attention they're just going
to win yes if I go to the average
college campus I can find a chick hotter
than any 30-year-old I would say maybe
75% of the chicks are hotter you know
the same way I would say the 30y olds or
I the same way I would say the
40-year-olds can't really compete with
the 30-year-olds and the 50-year-olds
can't compete with the 40 year olds I
mean water is wet the sky is
blue now obviously these were very
reasonable women very reasonable and
base raging it was actually the funniest
thing I've seen in a while and they
would be like well Pearl's right but
insert coat but I can get plastic
surgery and be young forever
okay but insert coat she's so hateful
and
but she's so ugly and I'm I'm the I'm
the hottest I am the epitome of
hot all right yes you are Miss hottie
anyways this was just hilarious
hilarious so funny um
so um I wanted to actually talk about
some stuff that's going on with the
network I am actually so proud of my
team right now in the past year year and
a half we really have improved our
processes so much and we've hired some
really awesome people like we have some
new editors we have some new thumbnail
designers um etc etc and really things
are really starting to to go where we've
really streamline streamlined our
processes so as you guys know I've
always had a vision of a network and I'd
like to say that every everybody has
advised me against doing the network
everybody has said Pearl why don't you
just focus on yourself why build all
these other people
up and I'll tell you why I think it's
fun Sumi some women have fun going out
to the club I love YouTube I've always
loved YouTube I think it's amazing I
look at it as an art and I just enjoy it
so and it's funny because everybody will
say
Pearl is this work you work so much well
work is fun to me I don't know what to
tell you um
anyways so let's talk about the updates
going on so my vision is I really see us
having content houses in different
cities I think it would be cool for this
to be an international thing that's my
vision and um right now I have one in
London and I really think we've
perfected the process for
London um however the drawback that I
found is starting a channel completely
from scratch is exceptionally difficult
and hard this is not an easy thing to do
and while I cracked the code replicating
this is not easy and what I found is
that when I sign Talent it is
exceptionally expensive it is not cheap
to sign talent and you automatically
will lose money if they have no
following immediately it was hilarious
because for a while I was accused of
having slave
contracts and do you know who the one
that was enslaved in these contracts was
me me I was like an indentured servitude
because I was the one paying for
everything yes these idiots have no idea
how much it costs to start somebody from
scratch if I told you the monthly costs
you would be
amazed so a way I thought of around this
is a network
page yes a network page so basically
we're going to have a network page and
people are free to use our resources
that have been on the show you know they
know who they are um to produce content
on this network page and once they build
a big enough audience on that that then
and you know basically I want you guys
to be involved and let me know what
talents you guys liked from the show and
you would want to be signed to the
network I want it to be like a
collaborative like we can do it together
so on this network page I was thinking
what we could do is have Series going
going and I have a couple ideas um
there's one guy who I thought would be
great for the moment of truth if you've
seen that show there's another guy who I
thought would be really good doing
Street interviews um there is a girl
that I think would be really cool to do
call-in shows and basically they'll have
little projects and series that we do
and we'll see how they go before going
all in on the talent and then you guys
can give me feedback on who you like for
the network and we can refine it and get
the perfect people to join because what
I realized is a lot of people do need to
be
developed in order to be a full-time
talent because the influencer world is
very Cutthroat there's a million people
trying to do what I do and what other
people do and that's how I I see it the
next question I've gotten is when are
you going to the US
um and this is a fair question because I
think last spring every time I go home I
think I'm have a woman I get all
emotional and I'm like I love being home
I want to be home and it's true there's
a part of me that does want to be
home um however my goal is to get a
couple talents here making money and
then go home um how long it's going to
take to do that I don't know um but my
goal is to have these Talent houses in
every city So eventually it could be
like the audacity Network Miami the
audacity Network London and I just think
it would be really cool and I've been
advised I'd like to to let you guys know
I've been advised against everybody to
not do this they've told me just focus
on
yourself and why do I do
this it's not like I need the money I
mean it's fun I like it you know sue me
you know some people just enjoy things
I've always looked at YouTube like
art some it looks like someone's getting
broken into their car or something I
don't know oh they got in
okay oh no it's going
again oh
gosh
but yeah so in the next year I'll likely
go
home um and in the next
year we are assigning talents
um the the only way around this network
page was if would be if they had a
pre-built audience so they're already
have an audience then they're an easy
sign but it actually takes a lot of
money and work to get someone from zero
to 2 million followers like I have I
know a lot of you guys think almost
anyways I know a lot of you guys think
this stuff is easy I'd like to say it is
not in fact easy it's actually very
difficult but so the shows on the
network page we've already started
filming um including a street interview
in Mexico done by Troy Francis going to
edit that this week um I did a panel
show um I want to do a female version of
The View basically that's a bit more red
pill and conservative um and more right
leaning it's going to be virtual to
start but ideally um in 6 months to a
year we'll get some regular talents that
we really like and maybe it'll be a big
hit and we can bring it to a a
city and produce it in person
um the moment of truth I want to
recreate
um was other one oh I want to
do a show called 1% women where we
interview 1% women in different things
um I know there's a million 1% like and
this is through one of the talents
Dimitri I don't know if you guys know
this but I was thinking it'd be
really um
no maybe not but I don't know I'm I was
thinking anyways we have a bunch of
talents that are coming
through CU I was thinking it'd be
interesting to interview like Homemakers
and like that sort of thing um so I
don't know we'll we'll see I have
different ideas and stuff coming
about um so let me know what you guys
think what type of shows you'd like to
see in different projects um
like the video and
subscribe and I don't know let me know
um but I will go back to the US
eventually I will but I just don't know
when but like the video guys subscribe
I'll talk to you next time